une revendication sociale est en pointe
c'est la semaine des 35 heures nous
sommes en 1979 et l'idée de la semaine
de 35 heures agite la gauche françois
mitterrand candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 1981 en fait l'éloge
le problème des 35 heures n'a pas
simplement une vertu économique et
social par la création d'un million
d'emplois et là également une vertu par
rapport à l'idée que nous nous faisons
nom de la vie à savoir que le travail
n'est pas simplement une sorte que
l'asie pas simplement une petite annexe
du travail partagé le travail crée des
emplois dégager du temps libre pour les
travailleurs voilà les arguments pour la
semaine de 35 heures mais c'est
seulement près de 20 ans plus tard
qu'elle entrera dans la loi le scrutin
est ouvert les 35 heures sont entérinées
par deux lois en
1998 et en 2000 dit les lois aubry du
nom de la ministre de l'emploi de
l'époque martine aubry ce n'est pas une
loi contre les entreprises elle doit
leur permettre de mieux fonctionner et
si elle fonctionne mais demain si elles
sont plus compétitives c'est plus de
richesses et ses plus d'emplois dès le
début c'est un sujet explosif entre la
droite et la gauche tout le monde sait
que ça peut être une très grande réforme
de gauche et nous allons tout faire pour
que ce soit reçue et entre les patrons
pour qui c'est une aberration économique
la
quadra loire tout le monde le sait est
une erreur et les travailleurs pour qui
c'est le bonheur
pour bien commencer la semaine il suffit
de prolonger le week end chaque mois 6
millions de français pas tous dans le
bonheur des 35 heures mais dans certains
secteurs la réduction du temps de
travail n'a pas été synonyme de création
pote exemple à l'hôpital public ils
travaillent - les au bloc opératoire on
manque de bras à l'hôpital de pontoise
on applique les 35 heures sans moyen ni
recrutements supplémentaires
la majorité lance donc la grande
offensive
jean-pierre raffarin a déjà assoupli la
loi mais il dénonce encore et toujours
la démarche autoritaire des 35 heures
amendé assouplie mais jamais supprimé on
les accuse souvent d'avoir augmenter le
coût du travail d'avoir été soutenu
financièrement par l'état et que dans
les faits les français travaillent plus
que 35 heures mais ont-elles alors créer
des emplois
c'est vrai selon des calculs effectués
par l'insee mais beaucoup moins que
prévu selon cet économiste
on est vraiment dans des créations
d'emploi nettes significatives 350
milles qui ne permet pas de réduire
massivement le chômage mais ça n'a pas
non plus eu des conséquences aussi
négatives pour le pense des conséquences
pas aussi négative qu'on le pense et qui
aujourd'hui relance un nouveau débat
devrait-on aller vers la semaine de 32
heures
[Musique]